now that there's a new Black Panther on
the scene the balance of power in the
MCU is about to change in more ways than
you might think the official trailer for
Black Panther wakanda forever teased it
and the movie has no problem confirming
it there's a new Black Panther in town
and her name is shuri however this is
not the playful happy-go-lucky shirt
that fans might remember from Black
Panther much like her predecessor and
brother t'challa she goes through a
great deal of loss and sorrow before
fully embracing her role as wakanda's
protector not only does t'challa himself
die unseen in the early stages of the
movie but wakanda forever antagonist
namor's attack ends up killing her
mother Queen Ramona shuri starts the
movie in denial over the spiritual world
and the Black Panther tradition
preferring to focus on science instead
however Ramona's death and the impending
threat of namor's talocon forces cause
her to return to an old project an
artificial Recreation of the
heart-shaped herb with the help of her
old research t'challa's DNA and a gift
from Neymar sure he manages to create a
new version of the plant that gives
black panthers their power and promptly
uses it up until now the heart-shaped
herb had been treated as a highly unique
commodity that was lost forever when
killmonger destroyed the remaining crops
burn it all
now the Cherry has figured out a way to
replicate the precious plant however it
might have a huge impact on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
judging my house shuri manages to go Toe
to Toe with Neymar in the finale it
seems that her artificial heart-shaped
herb is comparable to the original and
seems to be at least as potent as the
other prominent superpowered substance
in the MCU Abram erskine's super sulfur
serum which famously turned Steve Rogers
into Captain America as it happens the
super soldier Serum is a huge deal in
the MCU for decades scientist after
scientist and Nation after nation has
tried to replicate the effects of
erskine's serum after the original
recipe was lost with Erskine himself the
results of these often dubious
experiments have ranged from Red Skull
and the Abomination to us agent in the
flag Smashers so imagine what will
happen when the world finds out that
wakanda is sitting on a substance that
can make people at least as powerful as
Captain America the day the world
discovers the existence of shuri's
heart-shaped herb could be nearer than
you think too because there's one person
outside wakanda who already knows about
it the Riri Williams doesn't witness the
entire process of recreating the
heart-shaped herb she is present during
shury's ingestion ritual as such she has
a good idea of how the herb is used and
at the risks involved what's more she
specifically requests some for herself
after seeing its effects on shuri while
that line about wanting to try the Earth
herself is played as a joke wakanda
forever establishes Riri as a highly
intelligent person with an inquisitive
mind if a rather obvious gadgeteer
genius parallels with Tony Stark
continue it would be almost surprising
if she didn't end up tinkering with the
version of the recipe or using her
connection with shuri to learn more
about the new heart-shaped herb she
might even inadvertently reveal its
existence to somebody if that happens or
shuri's new heart-shaped herb recipe
gets out of wakanda in some other way
the MCU could be looking at a whole new
generation of super soldiers running
around the block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]